can you share with us one of your
earliest memory
you okay
I'm picture right now those antique
furniture from my grandma's house in the
city of Hermosillo Mexico like imagine
them oak Oak and other kinds of wood
lots of force Lando's many porcelain
figurines the smell stagnant smell of
old furniture with the kitchen with
grandmother's perfume
sometimes it robs you oxygen from your
health and make comics your Deezy at a
practice of a second but you think you
get like used to it and kind of forget
about it after after our play with my
brothers sisters and cousins where which
were also around the same age just
running around earliest memories
is when I misspell pomegranate the first
time and it was like something right B
um or something very terrible and that's
literally my first memory and I mean I
can't believe it but it's okay I mean we
all make mistakes right when I were
young actually my brother he
used to sell dates in the street so when
he came back at home he lets me
she let me pick the rotten dates from
like thousand thousand eight that was
very awful and I was crying and I didn't
wanted to do it but I was offered to do
it
it's a bad memory month today we do your
job is to pick the rotten one yeah and
he would go and sell the good oh yeah he
got to sleep I beg the roses my cousin
his name is Gerald and he stole my
scooter and then the next like two hours
or so he got ran over by a car and he
broke his foot so that's the earliest I
remember but I was really mad because he
stole my scooter but then I felt sorry
because I went to the hospital and he
broke she's fine karma huh this is
really funny one eye when I was around
like four or five I had just discovered
the network and
I was in the back of my house and I I
don't know I was really distressed and
by my dad you came to the back
he wanted me to do something but I
didn't want to do it so I just said [ __ ]
it and then now it balanced by the worst
beating of my life but it was very
memorable because I felt like the f-word
was
[Music]
just in the moment it was like a viewing
that
[Music]
make me happier the same the f-word as I
said it one of my earliest memories I
was such probably three years old we had
a wood-burning stove and my mother was
stoking it for the evening and she put
in some kerosene and it exploded on her
face and she put on a salve called
beautiful picture it and then she came
to kiss me good night
yeah I was into my little crib and she
had it looked to me like she had a
relish spread all over her face it was
scary and then it was funny okay so when
I was like like a baby like two or three
years old I was lying down on the bed
place myself in a weird position
and I just kept thinking to myself okay
years from now I'm gonna remember this
very memory of me lying down weirdly on
the bed
I remember like when I was about two
years old
round four
just around like my house kind of
wandering what do you think it stands
out
I don't know I think there's a lot of
going on at my house at that time and so
I think I just was kind of picking up on
the energy in the house
what kind of I'm not good negative
family trouble when I was that age my
mom was going through a lot
[Music]
seeing my friend commit suicide when I
was young I guess that's probably like
one of the things that stuck with me my
entire life and I don't know it's never
went away so it's crazy because I can
toast immediately because it was so
traumatic actually but my earliest
memory is getting into a really bad car
accident
my mom was hit by a drunk driver and I
remember being in the car crying and we
had all these people coming up to the
windows and I was hysterical
but I was the only one she wasn't hurt
so I don't know why I said I was crying
that much but I was four and I remember
being put in the stretcher and having my
neck held down and I was very confused I
think my parents putting me to bed one
night and I could see them both in the
doorway
why did that
it's one of the few times I saw them
likely I guess I don't know it's a scary
memory when I was in California for the
first time and my family was walking in
front of me they were like busy already
and they get the elevator door closed in
front of me so it started going up like
12 stories so I thought it was gone
forever I was gonna just keep going up
so I fell asleep in the elevator because
they got so scared
well more like fainted and then when I
woke up I was in the car and they didn't
even explain what happened that's pretty
much it
shoving of our soap in my sister's mouth
and making her poop and poop in the tub
I was in as well so like my favorite
childhood memory oh my god she like
stood up really fast she scraped her
back my mom was so mad it was such a
disgusting bath after that like blood I
have a twin sister and we were always
together we were inseparable growing up
and then one day we went to daycare and
a teacher tried to separate us so I
kicked her and I got in trouble but from
that day forward we were separated after
that so she was hurt when my sister was
born I was six and I clearly remember
the day she was born and I Heather it
was
the most amazing feeling in the world oh
cool just to see you I used to drink
soda and like put it in my shirt instead
of my later earliest memory I remember
myself
like I used to drink soda and put it
inside of my shirt instead of my mom
like instead of like opening my mouth up
important I would like pour it to my
liking shut up
yeah that's that's all I can remember
from back then - that's the earliest
memory I remember I was like four at the
time oh it's acceptable I was like four
years old the first time I rode my dog
sat on his back in row with my dog
totally we rode I wrote him around the
backyard and then I fell off and he came
back around and laid down next to me and
licked me and I got back on him and we
rode around a little longer listening to
Billy Joel's uptown girl while playing
the Gazoo to it and my Eman drops I was
around like three and my papa
my grandfather he had this like huge
garden my child imagination me like
thinks that like everything under the
Sun grew in there but I'm sure it was
like five things but I just remember him
handing me like Mitch and being like eat
this and I'd like to on the mint and
then he'd be like hand me a tomato be
like eat this and I like to eat the
tomato and like I just remember like
trailing after him in the garden like GT
whatever he handed me and like loving it
I think it was like the coolest
being in the world involves me my dad
saw this probably like younger than
three but he's laying on the hammock and
I'm laying on his chest and he's playing
the guitar and our old backyard it's a
really different way
what do you think that one stands out to
you
because it's just John Breaux close to
home you know real personal hey guys
thanks for watching another episode I
just wanted to come on there real quick
and let you guys know that next week
August the 16th will be a pretty special
day because it'll mark exactly one year
since I uploaded my first episode of the
project here on YouTube since it will be
pretty important date to me and
hopefully for you guys as well I thought
I'd do an episode that's different than
what I usually do a little something
planned yeah we gonna turn out good but
just remember that instead of posting
Tuesday next week I'll be posting on
Thursday August the 16th for those of
you who've been watching since the
beginning you will never know how much
it means to me so thank you again and
for those of you we just started
watching my videos thank you as well I
hope you all find the reason to keep
coming back and watching my episodes
here on YouTube and that's it